[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowlakes heads explode let me
be clear before this podcast begins we
are loud proud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them so when I was live
yesterday Jason chapit posted a picture
of his turkey that cost $14
I don't know if it's because he was
trying to prove that what I was saying
wasn't true about the Kelly bronze
turkey or not I don't I don't know what
he was trying to do um but I only have
to assume that Jason Chait was very
upset that I pointed out that he's a
[__] turkey
snob you know what's funny about
this is almost every MAA supporter
relative that you're going to have and
talk to this Thanksgiving
holiday where Jason chaitz bought this
turkey and how he bought this turkey and
the turkey that he bought they'd be like
that's some woke ass [__] right there
that's some woke ass Turkey right there
I I'm just tired of this wokeism and
these woke
turkeys $114 he paid for his turkey and
it's from some [__]
Farm
organic it's organ what the [__] kind of
turkey in organic what are you talking
about organic I I can't stand that [__]
I can't stand that [__] to be perfectly
honest with you organic when you go in
and they're like hey here's the regular
strawberries here's the organic ones
what the [__] do you think a strawberry
is are you [__] [__] me you want me
to pay extra money because you typed out
the word organic on the label get the
[__] out of here oh well but but Tony
they they don't use this and and it's
it's grown like this and listen I grew
up on a [__] Farm
okay I know I know that that all animals
are organic all vegetables and fruits
are
organic but Jason chaitz buys into this
wokeism stuff that's right Jason Chait
is woke he bought himself a woke ass
turkey
that's basically how you should frame it
this Thanksgiving if this turkey gate
stuff comes up my most likely it will
not come up but they might they might
just say some [__] about gas prices like
Mark Wayne Mullen a that lion [__]
little [__] Mark Wayne Mullen are you
kidding
me he's bitching about diesel prices
one one
diesel prices one diesel right now and
has been for a long time more expensive
than gasoline I don't really understand
it I I've never understood that because
diesel is the byproduct of making
gasoline if you know anything about that
so it's weird that it's more
expensive but it's probably the same
thing with the
eggs there's a story speaking of food
prices and prices and inflation
it's all Bon's fault them egg prices
it's all Bon's fault remember when they
were bitching about
that you remember that you remember when
you go to the grocery store and a
[__] dozen eggs cost $4 do you're
like what the what the
[__] are they feeding these chickens
cocaine or what the [__] how are they
making these
eggs apparently in federal court two of
the major egg
producers got sued and lost because they
were uh gouging prices well son of a
[__] it wasn't actually inflation
wouldn't you know it I'm not kidding you
that's a
thing yeah fre says eggs have gone down
the reason why eggs have gone down is
because they had to go down because they
caught them price
gouging so I you know I'm not sure if
it's it's the same thing with diesel but
Mark Wayne
Mullen bitching about having to fill up
his
F250 oh my
god of course Mark Wayne Mullen has to
has to buy a pickup truck to make up for
the size of his dick which he probably
doesn't have a very big one that's why
he's got to have him a big giant
truck and it's got to be diesel too
because you know that makes you [__]
tough if you drive around a diesel
because you
know spending more
money on fuel is important when you're
trying to show off your dick size you
know what I mean it's real important
yeah I mean baton Joe bad Joe Baden
forced me to buy this big truck and he
forced me to make sure it had a diesel
engine so I had to buy the more
expensive fuel it's all Joe padden's
fault just like the turkey
gate Jason chait's organic turkey is
organic his organic turkey I'm so happy
I'm so
happy that Jason chaitz bought the
turkey that says organic on it
h i mean I wouldn't want much more for
him would
you Jesus
Christ but you know that's that is the
actual brand of Republicans they're
elitist folks they're elitist and they
[__] about how they're elitist
again Mark way Mullen was forced by Joe
Biden to buy that F250 and forced by Joe
Biden to make sure that it had a diesel
engine in that
F250 forced him it's all Joe Biden's
fault Jason chaitz was forced to buy
that turkey forced to buy that organic
turkey for
$114 because everyone knows that Jason
chaitz couldn't stand to go into a
Walmart with all the
pores he definitely definitely does not
want to be seen or caught out in public
with normal average working
Americans they smell funny you know what
I mean
they smell like they're eating
and
$33 and I figured Jason chaitz probably
bought one of the chicken or the turkey
breast from Kelly bronze
farms and I was
wrong but I wasn't that far off was
I he paid
$114 it's $5 a
pound of turkey when you go to when you
go to walart and get one for
like 50 cents a pound 75 cents a
pound I mean I mean these people's
shopping habits how is this Joe Biden's
fault Ty points out a good point here
and the same turkey that he bought
people went back to the Wayback machine
I'm going to show you this they went on
the Wayback machine which basically is
the internet time machine you know what
I mean
mean and they looked at the price of
this same ass turkey this organic turkey
what the [__] does that
mean could someone find out if there is
an
stuff you're like Tony you're you're
talking down to us what do you mean
talking down to I I don't know what
you're talking about the [__] organic
strawberries look the same as [__]
strawberries they're both organic go
look up the goddamn
word anyways
anyways that same
turkey that Jason chaitz bought spent
$114 on in
20120 under um Donald Trump it was
$156
so it's actually cheaper now under Biden
so he should be thinking thaning Joe
Biden thanking him that he's only paying
$114 for a
turkey it's so
stupid what a bunch of
[__] every [__] last one of these
people are just [__] even Mark Wayne
Mullen talking about the diesel prices
gasoline and fuel prices are are the
they're going to be the lowest this
holiday season that they've been since
2020 fuel prices are going to be the
lowest that they've been since 2020 and
the only reason why they were so low in
2020 is because we had I don't know a
[__] pandemic going
on and not as many people traveled that
year travel was down so the demand for
fuel was down so the price for fuel was
down these aren't complicated things you
think that these self-proclaimed free
market
capitalist would understand this
[__] you think they get it in their thck
cty skulls but they don't because they
don't care they're not lying to
us I want to reiterate that they're not
lying to us people who have enough brain
cells to rub together to create a
thought and to go you paid
$114 for a turkey and that's somehow Joe
Biden's fault what the [__] are you
talking
about Mr Mr woke ass
organic what are you talking
about they're not talking to us they're
lying to the
Sheep do you know how many and how fewer
sheep there are
getting
I know they know it but it feels like
the media is really kind of trying to
brainwash normal average Americans that
that's not actually happening I keep
seeing poll after poll after poll and
people talking about shut the [__] up
about these polls they are so [__]
wrong it ain't even funny and even if
they are right who gives a rat's
ass who gives a rat's ass you can't
believe them anyways even if they are
correct you can't believe them so it's
not even worth mentioning
them folks there are fewer and fewer and
fewer manga
sheep they're getting fewer and fewer
because really honestly having to talk
or defend our [__] even think about
Trump Republicans MAA them being a bunch
of [__] Nazis compared to
Nazis oh don't believe me you remember
the Marl race in Franklin
Tennessee where Gabriel Hansen was
running around with a bunch of Nazis we
covered that this year remember all the
Nazis in Ohio protesting drag shows
because Republicans wanted to Outlaw
drag do you remember all the Nazis this
year protesting on an overpass in
Florida in support of Ron de santis I
think I remember these things I don't
know if you do what about what about
Trump using the words blood poisoning
and Vermin refer referring to liberals
and Democrats in this country like he's
going to execute or exterminate or send
them to camps do you remember that [__]
this year how about Ronda
santis talking about how if he becomes
president which he will never be
president of the United
States he will learn how to walk in high
heels before that [__] becomes
the president of the United States
talking about how he's going to shoot
and execute brown people at the border
because they got a backpack
on because he doesn't believe and due
process of
law I remember
that
do you remember all the laws that these
State Republicans were trying to pass to
ban books to ban trans children to ban
gay marriage to try to get rid of
women's rights to reproductive Health
Care huh Banning and criminalizing
women's privacy and their health care do
you remember all these Nazi type things
that happened this
year there's plenty to talk about at
Thanksgiving dinner folks oh baby is
there plenty of
issues you could talk about how Taylor
Swiss boyfriend is one of the best
fullbacks in the NFL or
or you could talk about [__] that is
kitchen table
issues like the fact that gas is down
and it's the lowest that it's been since
2020 how that turkey that you're
eating even even if you bought the
organic even if you bought the organic
expensive woke ass
turkey God what a [__]
[__] is
still $40 less this year than it was in
2020 you could you could talk about all
kinds of things at the kitchen table
at the Thanksgiving dinner as it
were yes someone's pointing out that
he's a tight end not a fullback I'm
sorry I'm sorry oh I don't know the
sports ball thing good enough alls I
know is that he's Taylor Swift's
boyfriend [__] out of
here I mean isn't that all that matters
at this point is that he's Taylor
Swift's
boyfriend
there's all sorts of things to talk
about at the Thanksgiving dinner
table all sorts of
things to talk about but the one thing
that you must do on this Thanksgiving is
realize and I think you'll come to this
realization when you start getting out
there and
seeing how little even your manga family
wants to defend the these actions of
these [__] criminal Republicans these
Nazi
Republicans it's
shameful that here in America we have to
continue to act like that there's two
serious parties trying to do serious
government so that we the American
people can continue on doing what we're
doing on our dayto day
but nope we can't do
that we have to be hyperfocused because
there are fascists in our midst trying
to tear apart our democracy trying to
topple our way of life in this [__]
country take away our economy I mean
Jesus Christ the Republicans twice three
times this year three times this very
year three
times wanted to take the economy on the
brink because why because they don't
know what the debt ceiling is because
they didn't want to fund government
because they thought Donald Trump was
being
persecuted because he was indicted and
being prosecuted for crimes that he's
committed [__] out of
here and then they
pretend like they did something big
kicking the the CR the continuing
resolution into January past the
holidays so we don't talk about it at
the Thanksgiving dinner table cuz that's
why they did
it they did not punt the continuing
resolution into January because it's a
good
idea they didn't want to shut the
government down right before
Thanksgiving that would be everything
that anyone was going to talk about this
weekend and can you imagine your MAA
relatives if they still want to defend
Trump and defend Republicans at this
point do you think they would have had
good
cause to sit and defend a government
shutdown no and that is the point that I
want to make to you the audience before
you go off on your holiday before you go
see your family members before you sit
down
to eat your organic
$114 turkey Jason
chaitz is that defend your
positions but more than
anything make sure that your family is
willing to defend
theirs that's
right you don't have to do it quite in
the Tony Michaels style you don't have
to have as many words peppered in there
is
possible but make sure they defend their
positions when they're talking to you
and make sure that you force feed them
that defense look
here Uncle
Bob the party you're voting for wants to
get rid of your socialism payment that
is sent to you every month they want to
get rid of your socialized health care
that you love so
much make them defend their positions
make them defend why they want these
fascists to take over this country why
they want project
2025 the blueprint for America to become
Nazi
Germany make them defend it I do have a
picture here of an or
[Music]
[Applause]
throughout the holiday season now I'll
give you the promo code we've got a sale
it's the Black Friday Thanksgiving
weekend whatever the hell you call it
now Black Friday starts like three
Fridays before the actual Friday now I I
don't know why don't I just called a
Thanksgiving sale for crying out loud
Black Friday ain't even Black Friday
anymore is it I don't know you don't
[__] shop that day you shop before
you shop online you don't go to the
store you remember you remember when you
had to wear your [__] boots and bring
a [__] a a knife now you had to
defend yourself on Black Friday you know
what I'm talking about you go to Walmart
early in the morning people be crowding
in the store I mean you have to pull a
knife sometimes to [__] defend
yourself that's [__] crazy people get
killed on Black Friday you know they get
a cheap TV well I mean Jason chaitz if
you spend money on Turkey like he did
you'd have to go on a Black Friday sale
to get a cheap ass TV you didn't have
that money left
over
but I've got a promo code for you I've
got a promo code for you if you go to
the Tony michaels.com and you click on
click on the tattoo
merch or the my dog hates Ted Cruz merch
let me show you that here if you go
there and you use the promo Cod code
promo code God I need a holiday promo
code turkey 12 that's
turkey 12 you get 12% off your entire
order just go to the Tony michaels.com
click the tattoo merch collection or the
my dog hates Ted Cruz collection you'll
be able to get coffee mugs you'll get
hoodies you'll get t-shirts they're all
there in those two stores and it's the
same promo code for both stores same
promo code so go to the michaels.com
click the tattoo merch collection or my
dog hates Ted Cruz merch and use the
promo code turkey 12 that's turkey 12
for 12% off your entire order it doesn't
matter what you order from those stores
you get 12% off as much as you want all
weekend long going all the way into
Sunday so from now until Sunday go grab
your merch and I really appreciate um
you guys supporting the show not not
only through the merch sales but as we
get into the holiday
season um I'm going to be taking more
and more Sunday rants off I'll probably
take a few of the producer Corners I
know this Friday we won't have one so we
won't have a show tomorrow or Friday now
I'll be back on Monday and I won't have
a Sunday rant this Sunday I'm gonna take
that time for for that but just use the
use the code turkey 12 that's turkey 12
and go to the Tony michaels.com either
click into the tattoo merch collection
or the my dog hates Ted merch collection
and you can use that promo code turkey
12 it's turkey one2 that's turkey
one2 they're in
there yeah I figured turkey was a good
one I was gonna do like Black Friday or
something like that I like Black Friday
doesn't even exist anymore
does it I don't think it
does I mean they're like oh it's a Black
Friday sale it starts on Sunday like
what that's not
Friday I mean again there's a lot of
people out there that probably remember
Black
Friday Black Friday big time am I
leaving now no I'm not leaving now what
are you talking about no no we're not
leaving now we're doing a whole two
hours we got a we got a guest today
normally we would have Cliff Sher on
Thursdays but tomorrow's Thanksgiving so
we're not gonna have a show so we got
cliff on today that's right we got Cliff
here today so if you want to stick
around and watch Cliff you're gonna want
to stick around and do that so I am I am
so glad you guys uh are here on
Wednesday I figured I figured a lot of
people would be traveling a lot of
people would be busy prepping uh for the
Thanksgiving holiday I'm trying to do
those travel preparations maybe getting
to the airport uh in the car but I'm so
glad that that you guys are here uh with
us and Cliff is going to be with us when
we come back again don't forget this
weekend if you want to use the promo
code and get 12% off you just go to the
tony.com pan on down to the merch stores
click on either one of these that that
code will work in either one it's turkey
12 that's turkey one2 that's turkey 12
turkey2
and you can use that promo code it helps
the show here helps support the show it
gives you guys a discount uh on the
merch get you guys a this machine kills
fascist tattoo that's right I'm gonna
get that tattoo this this right here
that's what's on the the tattoo Merch
this design right here that's on the TV
back here if you can see it I'm gonna
get that tattooed on my arm in January
right here so you see a microphone right
here so you guys will actually be
wearing or if you're drinking out of a
coffee cup the merch that is inspired by
the tattoo that will go on my arm I hope
your guys's Thanksgiving preparations
are going
swimmingly why wouldn't I want this
holiday where us white
folks
celebrate us genociding indigenous
people it's really weird it's a really
weird American thing that we do on this
Thanksgiving holiday isn't it I think it
is you may
not but when you know the truth the
truth is the truth and here's the truth
we'll be right back right after this
we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds this
is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast trying to remember all the
things you boycotted can really get you
stressed because there's no good way to
keep them from becoming a cluttered mess
well now there's boycott binder the
ingenious organizer that keeps track of
everything and everyone you've ever
boycotted the 72 category filing system
makes it easy to organize boycotted
people places and things so you can find
them with ease the large centered area
can even fit your boycott sign but best
of all when you're done the boycott
binder folds right up so you can take it
anywhere so if you're tired of having a
cluttered mess call now and get the
boycott finder for just
$29.99 plus you'll also receive our next
rep as a bonus just Loop it around your
neck to travel with ease but call right
now and we'll double the offer that's
two boycott binders and two neck straps
for just
$29.99 boycott binders brought to you by
the same makers of binders full of
women jumping back into it this is the
Tony Michaels podcast
C welcome back to the
show turkey gate is on
[Music]
going we think inflation is the
problem I don't
know they think inflation is the big
issue I mean inflation is a big issue
especially when it's you know price
gouging that's when it really becomes an
issue like in courts and
[__] I don't know if you remember um
it's been months ago though that egg
prices were just
astronomical it was
crazy but good news is is that yesterday
uh two egg
producers um were found to have be
liable for price fixing here let me show
you this report here this is Tristan
Snell today egg producers liable for
price fixing
scheme per new verdict in federal jury
the top two egg producers Cal M and Rose
acre the the two top industry groups
were raising and fixing egg prices
hm case now moves to damage phase yes
inflation was partly price galling H
well son of a
[__] what do you know what do you know
corporations were taking advantage of us
going well I mean I guess prices just
going to go up and
stuff corporations taking advantage of
that
attitude so it's not surprising that
Jason chaitz and Mark Wayne Mullen are
trying to convince us people who have
brain cells to rub
together that $114 turkey I'm not
kidding you watch look at this look at
this I put it on the thumbnail let me
show you this picture here let me show
you this picture here you go here's his
turkey this is his [__] turkey that
he was talking about here it is
$114
what what an idiot I mean but it is
organic
right it is organic I don't know I you
know it's funny because if any if if any
liberal would post this online that they
paid $4.99 a pound for a turkey
right
$114 the right-wing would be like oh
you're so woke I can't believe bu such a
woke turkey all right mother woker you
and your woke ass bird like what the
[__] are you doing man buying a a turkey
that's F I mean you know maybe it tastes
really good I
mean turkey really depends on how you
cook it how it tastes I mean most people
cook that some bits till it's dryer and
[__] right that's why they got to spread
the gravy all over it that's why you dip
it in the taters and the and the noodles
and all that [__] you know so so it
doesn't taste like [__] I mean you're
going to eat the turkey whether it
tastes good or not I know I know that
you're gonna eat the turkey whether it
tastes good or not I Cliff I want to
know if you are gonna eat the turkey
whether it's good or not how are you
Cliff how are you besides everything
technical going wrong so that my sound
stucks uh everything else is great oh
well then you sound fine to me I can
hear you I think okay I think there's an
echo because my office and you know
there's a mic that's supposed to be
working and it's uh oh we're good to go
I blame Jason chait's [__] turkey is
what I
blame probably look at this SP that kind
of money on my mic I'd have no problems
I right by the
pound issues here you know what's funny
about this is that he he could have said
on Fox News because he claimed that it
was a $90 Turkey right if I'm not
mistaken he said he paid 90 and it was
all Joe Biden least 90 he maybe even
said was over 100 I mean he said
something ludicrous I think he said 90 I
think well I mean it is ludicrous he
paid $114 for the turkey now
yesterday I actually I I went to see
what is like the most expensive turkey
in the country and I found a place
called kelly bronze it's a farm in
Virginia um and and they also have a
farm in UK but they claim I I mean they
prepared turkeys for the queen um you
know and you know they have a whole list
of famous people that have bought their
turkeys waiting to hear how much this
[__] costs though n n pound turkey
$133 for a N9 pound
turkey yeah I'm not gonna say on even on
your show where everything's allowed
what that turkey better do to me for
that kind of
money at the very least that turkey you
better do some chores around the house I
mean help out a little bit right I mean
right that's a lot of money for nine
pounds of turkey but I mean the funny
part is is he says on Fox news that the
turkey cost $90 which is a lie because
it actually cost 114 so he could have
actually said look this turkey was
$115 I mean even if you're rounding up
wrong
11402 and you round up to 115 he totally
could have blamed
$115 on Joe Biden than $90 on J so what
you're saying is he's both a liar and
stupid I mean it is Jason J have you
ever have you ever listened to him party
in general if he can if he he wants to
go for the trifecta he should just uh
challenge some to a fight someone to a
fight like Mark Wayne Billy Bob Thorton
and then uh you know we can all find out
that he also has a small penis and know
that he's he's got issues there too well
I I mean speaking of Mark
Wayne small dick energy um here is here
is um you should that tweet from his
truck I mean that's that's what I'm
gonna that's that's what I'm showing
right here here's here's the tweet that
he showed um it says Joe Biden doesn't
want you to believe your own pocketbook
Mark Wayne says Mr tough guy I just
filled up my truck oh Jesus an F250
power stroke
diesel I mean that's that's really when
he's typing this out I feel like that's
how he was actually saying it oh you
know he was he he he's trying to
convince himself he's got a real Power
Stroke right an F250
power you know that's how I figured that
he he he refers to his
truck from for
$468 c a gallon now first off let me
tell you
something obviously Joe Biden forced
Mark Wayne to buy the F250 power stroke
diesel I mean he probably held him held
him at gunpoint um to buy this truck oh
this big huge truck that obviously is to
compensate for Mark Wayne's little penis
he bought this big truck when he debates
people he apparently has to stand up on
a shoe box to to debate them because and
again I'm not a tall man I'm not making
fun of anybody for being short it's more
that you can't live with the fact that
you're short and that it affects your
that somehow you're like these guys like
Ronda santis who's who if he wears any
taller heels will be in the reboot of
staying
alive you know like they're just they're
so insecure about everything it's just
oh my God go ahead so so not only did
Joe Biden Force Mark Wayne to buy this
Paro diesel but he also forced him to
pull into the gas station where the
diesel fuel is 468 a gallon now I don't
know if people know this but a lot of
people don't drive diesels one of the
reasons why is because the fuel is more
expensive now a diesel engine is likely
more efficient right so you're kind of
doing a tradeoff where you get better
gas mileage for a big truck if you have
the diesel engine in it than if you have
a gasoline engine in it but yeah you
know who's counting maybe Mark Wayne
doesn't know that maybe he was just like
yeah the power stroke that sounds like I
got a big dick so he really wasn't
considering like G uh the I don't think
I don't think he will how many times by
the way you think he drives the power
stroke there through a tunnel every day
back and forth just to feel you know
just to feel big feel good about himself
yeah well probably probably I I have I
have no idea why he's driving around an
F250 powerstroke diesel other than to
compensate for his dick but he says he
said that's in Oklahoma and I'm not sure
exactly what that means I guess he's
saying you know gasoline is produced
here but I mean gasoline is and Diesel
is kind of produced all over the United
States that and there's the fact that
that yeah like it would be cheaper
because it was produced in Texas and
Oklahoma you know unless there's
something I don't know I mean in the end
the main reason it's it's as expensive
as it is because they gouge the living
crap out of all of us they know we need
energy and you know we're doing our best
here at least I mean Biden obviously
passed something that was historic with
the inflation adjustment act which was
to to move us and you know put more
money into green energy than had ever
been done before so we're trying to head
in that direction but until then these
guys have us by the balls and they can
they can drive up prices all they want
you know I mean that's that's real well
and I show I was showing the audience
the egg the egg producers who were just
found liable right who who were
colluding yeah right right well I I mean
and and that was a big huge thing I mean
everyone's like well how about the egg
prices and I remember going to grocery
like $4 for a dozen of are they feeding
crack to these chickens what inck again
what is this egg going to do for me
right right can I fly on this egg to La
like I want to know what for that price
I'm getting right which which was kind
of ridiculous but as soon as as soon as
the report started to come out and
journalists really started to
investigate why the a producers um were
were were setting these prices and the a
producers were like if you remember this
they produced like oh look we had a we
had a disease in a couple plants that
affected stuff which was all [__] it
was all [__] it was all chors like
you're saying they were coordinating
their price gouging so that they'd all
be able to price gouge at the same time
so it looked like it was just a market
something happening in the market right
because every industry at this point at
some point have we not caught every
industry doing this I
mean including the gasoline industry the
fuel industry like Mark Wayne is
bitching about here he says to tell
Americans that inflation isn't a problem
which Joe Biden is not saying inflation
is not a problem that is not a thing
that he is doing that's never been
nothing that he's doing but it's so much
worse in you know in other countries
he's done so much again you know the
inflation reduction act I finally got it
right saying the second time um you know
he I mean what he put in there are our
inflation has gone way down we are far
improved over where we were uh and you
look at these other countries like
Argentina just elected that baboon you
know that reminds them of trump and like
their inflation rates like 400% I don't
know off I'm it's something awful I'm
not don't quote me on that but like he
he when when compared and that's all you
can do is compare to your peers right
we're doing a pretty incredible job most
of other uh industrialized most other
sort of you know first world democracies
whatever you want to call them high
income countries are having bigger
problems than we are with this he has he
and his administration have combed this
but they the the in the end what the
Republicans realize is and we were just
showed it to them again here in Ohio and
you know with the abortion vote we and
here with the marijuana vote here and we
showed it to them obviously taking back
the the state house in Virginia as well
as holding the state senate you know
it's five Chambers we've taken back of
State legisl since uh during the years
when Biden's been in office the party in
power has hasn't done that since FDR um
I mean these are the kinds of things
that that are going on so these guys
realize the only way they can win is if
they stick with their story they repeat
it again and again and again and again
and again no matter what [__] it is
and people are not just their crazy base
but all people are living in an
alternate reality where they think crime
is awful inflation is terrible you know
the the Border crisis you know is is the
is the worst it's ever been there are
solutions by the way to any of these
issues that had even slight problems we
could solve any actual real challenges
we have at the Border tomorrow we had
numerous uh immigration bills and that
one that passed in a bipartisan way
meant to to give people a path to
citizenship in this country and impose
some fines and a waiting period and and
punish corporations that were hiring
people who who were undocumented all
these various things and 67 Senators
including about 15 20 Republicans voted
for it but the house didn't when was
that 2008 2010 I mean we we we've had
solutions to these problems they just
they don't want the solutions because
they need to run against something
because nothing they believe these days
pretty gets above about 35% in the polls
so they need this so they're just going
to keep saying you've seen a coordinated
campaign you've seen it on Twitter and
other places to to act like inflation is
terrible because they don't they don't
know what else to do everything else is
going really well every time they turn
around something good happens you know
for Biden well and that's and that's
really the key here is because they they
don't they don't want people to be
talking about the things that are
actually happening in the country here's
a good example here's this was on um I
believe this is Newsmax um Newsmax it
says top conversations people want to
avoid at Thanksgiving this is the the
top conversation so they're prepping
Their audience don't talk about the 2024
election definitely don't talk about
Trump don't talk about family drama and
Co gossip okay that's a little weird
Biden don't talk about Biden don't talk
about covid don't talk about personal
relationship jobs personal finance war
or conspiracy theories Cliff what else
are you going to talk about than these
10 things at Thanksgiving I mean where
is there anything else the weather can
we talk about that is that allow how dry
the turkey is I don't know yeah how dry
how much Jason chait's turkey cost him
mention party and we don't mention can
we just talk about that I don't know but
but here is here's Newsmax prepping
Their audience on what not here's the
things I don't want you to talk about
because they'll definitely hand you your
ass at Thanksgiving if you talk about
these things speaking of that I've got
I've got an image of the jolly green
Tyrant at at the Thanksgiving dinner
table here is your your uh Uncle Fred at
the U at the dinner table the jolly
green Tyrant this is we're all have a
jolly green Tyrant at our table so let
me so let me ask you because I know
you're probably going to celebrate
Thanksgiving so how do you handle the
Maga relatives at uh at Thanksgiving do
do you have MAA relatives that show up
and you have to talk to these people
well actually yes normally we have an
awful one that does but but luckily uh
is a cousin and whatever but the wife
has to work on Thanksgiving this year so
he's not coming oh D so actually there's
like one or two conservatives are going
to be there but they're actually they're
they're people that I can talk to who
don't like Trump who are sort of
reasonable conservatives in my family um
you know as much as conservatism can be
reasonable but I mean you know it's it's
far they're not Maga like you know
they're not magga types at all didn't
vote for Trump so so thankfully the one
really awful one will not be there and
they're getting fewer and fewer because
this idea that Trump is getting more
popular is really [__] stupid like
like the media buying these polls that
he's getting more popular and stuff like
what are you talking about I I have no
idea how how you people are buying these
these polls that aren't showing they're
not showing up in reality right like you
mentioned earlier the the the vote in
Ohio the vote in Virginia the vote in
Kentucky the vote in Pennsylvania for
crying out loud none of the fruit is
bearing from these polls that you know
like people look at the winds and not
even even the vote in Mississippi right
we lost by three and a half points in a
plus 15 or 16 Republican state that
means we gain 12 to 13 points on what
they should have won by you know on an
off year on an off year on an off year
which is which is which is wildly
unexpected yes the fact we came close to
winning the governorship of Mississippi
says a lot as much as anything else that
that that we just mentioned so I mean
you know when and that as you said that
we we had an incumbent but still that we
won in Kentucky and held on um I mean
it's that's what I mean and then that
same night CNN was showing their stupid
poll they just come out with that I was
sitting there looking at and I was like
the if if they cared about anything but
clicks and people watching their Channel
whatever you can look at these polls and
all you do is look at the first couple
breakdowns demographically and you'll
know that they're full of [__] right
away because right away when they when
they come to you and they're like you
know uh Biden is only up by nine points
among minority voters and he won them by
45 points in in 2020 yeah that's that's
not accurate you you know I don't know
what you're asking and who you're asking
and how you're doing it but but you you
start looking at those internals and
you're just like this is garbage um you
know I'm willing to admit Trump's closer
than he ever should be uh and that that
that Biden's not way ahead which is
distressing just because of what it says
about our country but but if you if you
sit there and you look at at numbers as
they should be Biden's ahead and he's
ahead in key States and you know we
still have to do our part because
they'll throw everything at him and we
have to come out and make sure and you
know it should be a a a a 45 State
Landslide like it shouldn't even but you
know I I have hope as much as I rip the
media it seems like the people like you
and me and there's a lot of us and you
other journalists columnists who've been
ripping the New York Times And The
Washington Post they finally did it they
finally started using the fword for
Trump and pointing out that he's a
fascist and there's a big article in
Washington Post comparing his rhetoric
to Hitler's and um you know the New York
Times had a headline and and and for
once and it started talking about
fascism I think they're feeling the
pressure finally where all the rest of
us are like we [__] had enough of
this and you know we're going we're not
going to sit here and take take it if
you sit here and you try to cleanse this
thing and act like this is some little
Democratic Democrat versus Republican
you know fight and and that there's not
broader implications here about our
democracy and women's basic rights well
then [__] you I'm gonna rip you in every
forum and every place I can and I kind
of feel like that's the way a lot of us
we're just tired of and I think it's
worked so it doesn't mean they're going
to be perfect they're going to still
suck by Nature because they do but even
if they're a lot better in sort of
sharing Stakes I've said this before and
I and you know I have to believe it it's
it's really important where you are too
you know where I am Tony I mean I'm in
Cincinnati and and you know our
newspaper takes a lot of cues from what
the New York Times does how the New York
Times portrays things affects newspapers
in smaller cities around the country
it's kind of like they give them kind of
like the this is the way it should be
kind of thing and and whether they do it
overtly or they just do it they end up
picking up the New York Times spin so
that's it's a really important thing
that that those guys are getting at
least something
right so I have some hope well and and
you know back to the journalism thing
and people these mainstream journalists
calling him a fascist uh I you know my
audience knows that I'm not very easy on
Joe Scarboro um that I I like to pick on
Joe Scarboro a little bit a Morning Show
well I mean yeah Joe Scarboro thinks
he's so smart but he's not as smart as
he thinks he is um but um but he's been
calling Trump a fascist here lately and
I'm I'm glad that Joe is finally finally
coming to his senses um but the right is
freaking out freaking out that on
Morning Joe that they're calling Trump a
fascist and of course I've been calling
him a [__] Nazi for many many years
now and I've been
calling years we've been trying to push
that so that people like Joe Scarboro
will do it and again yeah I'm no
Scarboro watcher I've got numerous
issues frankly but but the important
thing is is that that is a show that
sets the tone that places like you know
Politico and others get you know their
their marching orders from again whether
it's overt or not they see that they're
like oh that's what we should be talking
about today and it doesn't matter
whether it's fair or not it's reality
right and so the fact that Scarboro took
something like an eight minute segment I
mean it wasn't just a short drive by
either it was a long segment and he sat
there and he was going through the new
York Times peace and that's kind of my
point about the New York Times that's
the influence they have he was going
through their peace and saying you know
well dehumanizes the opposition check
right like like uses you know wants to
call in the military uh in civilian
populations checking all the different
ways Trump checks different boxes for
being a fascist and so when you get an
eight minute segment like that on on uh
Morning Joe and when you get then a New
York Times front page article on how
he's echoing you know other
authoritarian leaders in history and
they use the word fascist in the article
and when you get the Washington Post
going even further and saying making a
comparison of his rhetoric to Hitlers in
one of their articles then we're that
means we've done something we've changed
something because they weren't doing any
of this stuff before well and and you
know I was pretty tough on Joe even in
that eight minute segment because Joe
really the thing that he got wrong and
it really pissed me off of course
there's a lot of stuff that pissed me
off but the that really got to me is
that he wouldn't be so good at what you
did if there wasn't well that is true um
my strategic outrage is is is aimed
properly I believe but um but but Joe
Scarboro mentioned in that piece that
that it was the courts that saved us and
I'm like you son of a [__] that is why
you're that is why you're not getting
the respect that you are that you should
be on a show like you have because
you're you're totally negating that it
was the the voting population the voters
the ballots that saved this country in
2020 it was not the courts the court has
nothing to do with the courts just
upheld the work of the voters you
[__] idiot and that's the thing that
really pisses me off is that the the
media the elites the the ones that want
to sit back and and um talk about how
the how average Americans feel and and
want this country to be and where they
want it to go
um and they fundamentally don't even
understand all wrong NOA they do even
when they're saying the right things
they're still getting it wrong and
that's and that's the and I you know I'm
not sure if MSNBC producers watch this
show I I get suspicious sometimes
because I get a lot of people that will
send me clips from Jo Joan Reed um she
follows me on Twitter so maybe there's
something there but but um or Lawrence
odono at night or or someone else's
commentary and they're like hey Tony
they're saying the same thing you said
this morning they're now saying it and
they're saying this now they weren't
saying this before they're now saying
this because you're saying it and so I I
don't know if there's what I think it is
I think it's it's a lot I think you are
absolutely playing a role and I think
some others out there are playing a role
I think when a lot of us who are in
whatever you want to call it Independent
Media even though I've spent some of my
life in mainstream media doing various
things and still write the occasional
piece for the Daily Beast where I used
to write more regularly and do that kind
of stuff but when people like us are
doing that stuff and you know friends of
of ours who are columnists at USA Today
and and you know different I can think
of people like will bunch at the
Philadelphia in chir and and Rex hubke
at at USA Today and places people
friends of mine like that they're saying
this stuff all time and I think it
reaches a critical mass like anything
else when when enough people like you
and I are saying it in these kinds of
places enough people are writing it even
as columnists in mainstream Outlets
eventually they can't deny anymore the
front pages of these newspapers and
these cable shows they just can't and
they're they're hearing it from
everywhere and they find it like this
you know we have to go and and say this
we have to go and share this because
this is the simple truth and and you
know again Trump makes it easier I mean
in that way we are very lucky because
most somebody I think who was pointing
this out somebody who who I like and
follow was just saying you know he's
he's saying this out loud in a way that
you know since dictators of the 193s or
some of the farri fascists who ran in
Latin America in the
1970s those are the only other two times
that they could point to where you had
leaders literally saying here's what I'm
going to do to you I'm going to turn the
justice department against you I'm gonna
lock up my enemies here's who I'm gonna
lock up is I mean he's laying it all out
there so there's nothing left to the
imagination and it's not like oh G I
wonder he'll do that he's telling you
he'll do it it's pretty easy so if
you're a reporter and you know you don't
you don't even have to break some new
ground and say we put it all together
and figured out Donald Trump's gonna do
this he just [__] said it so just
write what he said you know and and it
it takes care of itself well you know I
I I've been saying that for a long to
time too that that Donald Trump when
he's saying some of the [__] he's saying
he's not talking to me and you he's not
talking to people who listen to us he's
not talking to reasonable Americans he's
talking to his sheep because he has to
get his sheep riled up he has to keep
the Sheep going he has to keep the whole
idea that he's going to save them from
whatever their beef is with Society um
he's going to save them from that and
that's and that's the one thing why he's
doing what he's doing you know why he's
barreling down this fascist road that I
don't I don't think he understands he
can't he can't stuff that cat back in
the bag which is really is really what
um we the pro-democracy Coalition need
to focus on and keep focusing on until
the election and the reason why is
because if that turnout's high and we
actually expose not just Trump but MAA
and Republicans for who they truly are
and what they're willing to do to other
Americans uh and our countrymen that are
amongst us our neighbors our friends our
family our church members the people at
the PTA and if we really expose what
want to do they're going to lose badly
yes then they that's the thing we expose
it we push it we make sure the media is
covering it we cover it constantly you
know covering it once isn't enough
covering it once a week isn't enough to
truly put it in context it needs to be
talked about every day and you do that
and they do that then he will lose in
the kind of landslide he should lose in
and his party will too um and so that's
what we have to hope for but we'll see
what happens sadly I must go well I I'm
going to talk about it every day but
tell folks where they can find you where
you're talking about it I talk about it
every day um it's ceker on YouTube
that's the best place trying to grow the
channel just like a good friend Tony
here so it's sector I saw some people
had in the comments earlier thank you
yeah my moderators drop links like uh
like it's going out a St so yeah you'll
find me I'll put some stuff in the
comments later if I get a chance you can
find me at Cliff Sher on that [__] hole
Twitter that idiot anti-semite running
it but it still affects things so we
have to be there at Cliffy she dir
threads and that's that's the deal so
I'm gonna jump because I got to do a
damn call but thanks thanks for coming
on thanks for Happy Thanksgiving my
friend have a safe holiday we'll see you
soon and all of you thanks so much Shor
everybody and and everyone stick around
we'll be right back as they say on radio
right after this don't touch that
dial what the [__] is wrong with you
people people it's a rhetorical question
at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy there's Tammy by the time we
reached DC we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way we got plenty of slim gems skull
near run out Natty light hope it don't
rain tomorrow so we can Circle the city
again here's Bob dear Bob I'm fixing to
send you some more of them Doritos you
like the red bag not the live loving
blue one in your absence I discovered a
rash on my neck and no it ain't no
hickey and I even seen my cousin Brody
in
ages stay strong wrong wipe your ass at
least once a day yours
tamy [__] them [__] [__] them [__] [__]
them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast welcome back to the show Happy
thanks [__]
giving Goble
Goble
gobble I've got some images to show you
here we we went through the U the
is that a turkey sudon that you
got you not making rant noises that's
who's been gobbling this whole time well
son of a [__] are you gonna what are
what does a rat eat during
Thanksgiving oh yeah see you like oh
okay all right all right I get it I get
it you know I liked it here's what I I
like my mashed potatoes I like to put
the corn in my mashed potato you like
corn in your mashed potatoes oh yeah
yeah it's pretty [__] good when you
put the sweet corn in your ters you mix
them around in there and that's that's
how you eat corn that's the best way to
eat corn I think is put them in the
mashed potatoes the hell of that gravy
stuff put the corn in there that's how
you eat mashed potatoes are you gonna
travel for the holidays there yeah okay
well you better be safe traveling I've
got a few more of your images I'd like
to uh show the audience here um this is
looks like a big huge fight at the
Thanksgiving dinner here everyone's
throwing around the the green beans
although everyone looks happy in this
picture uh maybe they're excited that
their Maga relatives didn't show up at
Thanksgiving the green bean games as you
have it here um also I want to show you
um the engine apparently that Mark Wayne
Mullen this is the uh little dick energy
engine that is on display it Mark
mullen's garage
appar
oh boy oh boy I'm super excited uh about
this Thanksgiving I I
definitely am U looking forward to
eating some turkey the the green beans
the the corn and the ters but pumpkin
pie is also on the list I love pumpkin
pie one of my favor do you like pumpkin
pie rat do you like pumpkin pie yeah do
you put the whipped cream on top of it
yeah that's the best way to eat it with
the whipped cream on top with the
whipped cream on top so let's do this
let's shoot the [__] I want you guys to
ask any questions that you can here in
the chat since it's Wednesday before
Thanksgiving let's have a little fun
let's not get too crazy here but if you
want if you have a question uh for me
just type it in the chat if you would
put a question mark in front of the
question and behind the question so I
can see the chat goes so fast sometimes
it's hard for me to point out exactly
which questions are wish but if you got
a question let's shoot the [__] as you
GNA I know I like to shoot the [__] here
on the Tony Michaels podcast every once
in a while um pan Pai rules them all pan
or pan how do you say it how do you say
pan do you say pan or pan rat which one
do you how do you say it pan oh okay pan
then all right pan pan pie
um Henda says I hate hate pumpkin pie
you hate pumpkin pie what what um
someone asked sweet potatoes or white
potatoes I like the white mashed
potatoes so good if you're gonna put the
corn in it it's got to be the white
potatoes if you're going to put the corn
in some people like sweet
potatoes or sweet potato pie have you
ever had sweet potato pie but you know
the white potatoes with the corn and
it's got to be sweet corn man you got to
dump the here's the secret dump the
sugar in the
corn that's where you go right with it
um will there be many Indie candidates
for Biden to win or will there be too
many Indie candidates for Biden to win
in 2024 I really don't think at this
point we
should be too worried about the general
election being stuffed with Indie
candidates now we have to call them out
we have to really Point them out I I
notice that um what's his [__]
idiot's name this Congressman that think
he's running for president against Biden
what's this guy's what's this guy's name
r oh yes yes Dean Phillips Dean Phillips
was talking [__] about KLA
Harris and he said he said this is how
stupid this guy is now I want to remind
you that Dean Phillips
is apparently the campaign manager and
who has picked out Dean Phillips to run
as president of the United States
against Joe but is Steve Schmidt you
know Steve Schmidt like a Lincoln
project Steve Schmid [__] that guy he's
the guy who helped pick Sarah Palin for
John McCain
folks and he's gonna go work for Dean
Phillips who the [__] is Dean who the
[__] is Dean
Phillips but in an interview Dean
Phillips was ask about KLA Harris and D
Phillips says KLA Harris should
run I'm like what
what KLA Harris should run she is
running what the [__] are you talking
about she's on the ticket she's the vice
president of United States she's going
to run on the vi what a [__] idiot so
like literally she's gonna be out
campaigning but Dean Phillips wanted her
to be out campaigning and I don't I
don't understand it but Rob Law I I
don't think I don't think we should get
too concerned about any candidates in
the general election um and the one
reason why is because it's going to be
hard for them to get on some of these
ballots like RFK Jr uh when he gets
there I know a lot of people are worried
about this no labels thing but I I don't
know if you noticed that Joe Mansion uh
[__] the bed last week when he when he's
like I'm gonna not run for US senate
seat and then a few people are like well
are you g to run as the No Labels
presidential candidate and it went over
like a wet fart in a white
thong it just didn't work out very well
no one gave a [__] no excitement no
Fanfare no
nothing because Joe Mansion is
irrelevant that's why he's not going to
be United States Senator anymore he put
himself in that position that's his
problem so I wouldn't get too I mean we
got to point it out we got to keep this
thing but MJ ask my favorite side
dish I don't know when I was a kid I had
an uncle a great uncle and he made
homeade noodles oh my [__] god like
home like he make the noodles and cut
them and [__] oh my [__] god homemade
noodles that
was Uncle Bill's homemade noodles
dude when I was a kid that was my
favorite side dish probably and and man
you could just you could dunk anything
in it put that [__] on top of the ters
take your turkey and put it in the
noodles oh my God it was so
good so
good some people are telling me um how
to say
pan
pan Pon see everyone says a little
different
pean Brendon leis is so everyone's got a
little different way of seeing pan or
pan you know what I mean I guess it
depends on which part of the country
you're from um
Tony who do you think would
won bonee head of the
week because we're not gonna have bonee
head of the week this week right we're
not I think Gabe Sanchez is gonna join
us here in a little bit because he's got
a show directly after this show today
today he's got a show what was that live
with Gabe Sanchez so I hope he joins us
here um so I can see if he's still
walking or if he's riding a bike his
skateboard or if he's got some
Wheels but um um who would boned of the
week have been
my guess is probably Jason chaitz more
than likely that was a really dumb
move
probably
okay yams with Marsh marshy Mellows on
top no I've never been the yams
marshmallows fan not gonna lie not gonna
lie I I'm I'm also not much on the
stuffing and I'm not much on the um
uh what's the other one
that Everyone likes I don't like the
some of the things I just I'm not I'm
not I like the pumpkin pie I like the
turkey I like the ters I like the green
beans but and the noodles the
noodles of course I won't have my Uncle
Bill's noodles this
year roast fried or smoked
turkey depends on the
year depends on the year we've had
smoked turkey before for um we've
actually put deep fried um turkeys
before like hillbilly
style you know like almost burn the
house down type fried the turkey and
then you know a lot of times we put them
in the in the oven but but when you
roast them in the oven and I I've done a
few turkeys this way that's right I've
cooked turkeys before but I normally do
the ham most people want me to do the
ham and I I do brown sugar and
pineapples is how I do the ham but
anyways back to the turkey because that
was the question here uh when I roast it
I actually use a t a bag um that that
seems to be the best way and little
secret I take a couple cans of chicken
broth and I dump it in the
turkey yeah I I dump the chicken broth
in the turkey just dump the chicken
broth in the turkey you know it's in its
ass stuff that turkey's ass with a bunch
of chicken broth as much as you can
really get you a big old can or a couple
small cans oh man just keeps that turkey
nice and moist and put it in a bag put
it in a bag that's how I would do it if
I were you and did you know that little
uh that little button thing that red
button thing you're not supposed to let
it pop apparently I don't know that's
what some people say [__] I don't know I
just look at the directions and cook it
per pound and then check the
temperature
um Carter says more importantly who is
Dean Phillips accountability partner I
don't know if it's Steve Schmidt is his
personal accountability partner I have
no idea um if they're trading porn maybe
maybe um Margie points out a a from
Brian here a question Tony will
Republicans be charged in January 6
Insurrection I mean they already have
been if you think about it but maybe
you're asking about members of Congress
is that what you're asking about maybe
that's what you're asking about is
members of Congress I mean I I guess it
could happen that way now that's one
disappointment that I've had with Jack
Smith to be quite honest um I I feel
like most of Jack Smith's motions and
rulings it sounds like Jack Smith and
his special counsel
office thinks that they have the ability
to save our country and I think that is
the wrong attitude I think Jack Smith
should be focused on Prosecuting the
crimes that happened on January 6 period
I don't give a [__] about the timing I
don't care about the election I don't
care about who's running I don't give a
[__] if there's a chance of someone's
gonna win Jack Smith should do his
[__] job
and he should prosecute every single
person to the full extent of the law and
he should do it appropriately in that
order
right not trying to [__] save the
country first I'm really disappointed
that Jack Smith only indicted Donald
Trump in the DC case because he wants to
hurry to get Trump convicted so that
they can 14th them um that's one issue
that I have with Glenn to and I know a
lot of people don't like when I talk
about this but what the [__] are you
going to do these people keep yelling
and screaming about the 14th Amendment
it's not me talking about the 14th
Amendment I'm not talking about it I'm
not the one chomping at the bit to use
the 14th in a way that it's never been
used before that's right it's never been
used this way ever in the history of our
country and if you say that it has been
you're like no but look at this one but
look at this one you're wrong
there has never been the 14th Amendment
used on a presidential candidate to
prevent someone to be on a presidential
ballot just hasn't been
done um so I don't know if Republicans
will be charged but I believe that there
probably are members of Congress that
could be charged and that's the
disappointing thing about the jacksmith
DC case is I think he could have went
ahead and charged them and we could know
more we could start to really put a
better picture together of what has
happened and what happened to our
country and what they tried to do to our
country than him trying to save the
country and prosecute Trump I think this
stupid [__] where we go out of our way
to treat Donald Trump differently than
any defendant because we're doing that
when when we act like we have to rush to
a prosecution and rush to this getting
done and rush rush rush that is not how
federal courts work that's not how
Federal Criminal prosecutions work and
that is not how we should treat him just
because he's special we should not treat
him like he's any other than any other
[__] defendant out there so uh let's
see what else what other um comments do
we have
here let's see let's see do we have any
more questions I like shoot the
[__] and it's nice that we get two on
Wednesday um
how far away does the nearest neighbor
live from you that's kind of weird Ben
but I mean you know that they live
across the street they live next door I
mean I don't I don't live in the country
now I grew up in the country when I was
a kid you know our nearest neighbor was
like a half mile
away I mean you could kind of see their
house from our house if you were
standing in the right
spot but we we lived out in the country
I don't live in the country now I don't
but a lot of people used to ask me when
I used to do my walking rants on Tik Tok
they were like wow you're yelling and
screaming down the street do do people
do people think you're crazy yeah they
think I'm
crazy of course they think I'm nuts now
let's see what other questions do we
have here um Tony why do do you think
poor white uh whites vote against their
own interest uh affiliate
a unen unated
bystander on YouTube asses Tony why do
you think poor
whites vot against their own interest
affiliation so it's kind of like you
know I I've explained this before um a
lot of people think it's one issues that
they vote on like a a like abortion or
something like that and again that's
that's um that's that that's that could
be right that they're one isue voters
but I think the affiliation vote is
actually what causes one isue voters
right their affiliation with the
church and their affiliation with their
Christianity through
republicanism and how they view that um
takes uh takes takes you
know gives them the ability uh to
justify voting against their own
interest in that way um it would be like
you know placing a bet on your football
team for the Super Bowl when you know
they [__] suck and they're not even
going to get into the playoffs
right you you might still get people to
do that because they believe that their
football team whoever it is um is is the
best team ever
so um noodles at Thanksgiving Hils to
the yeah R you you eat noodles at
Thanksgiving don't you every once in a
while do you eat Noles yeah [__] yeah
noodles at
Thanksgiving [__]
yeah hell's to the
yeah let's
see what else do we
get who puts marshmallows on sweet
potatoes that's so 90s the lesli the
Leslie
Michelle all right let's not let's not
get into to too many Thanksgiving into
the chat yet we're not even to
Thanksgiving
dinner and people are throwing punches
in the chat I have to say you guys this
chat and the chat is always
fast right because the chat box that I
see it has YouTube it has twitch and
when we're on Facebook which we're not
now but what we're banned I'm banned I'm
gonna try to fix that over the weekend
by the way um but
but here's the thing is that the chat is
so fast it's hard to watch it really is
it's hard to like keep track of like I
have to stop it and slow it down um and
then I I miss a bunch of stuff because
it keeps going but I can't see it keep
going anyways the the point is about the
chat is you guys are so engaged in the
show and you're not just engaged in
exactly what I'm saying you guys are
engaged with each other like sometimes
in these chats there's three or four
different conversations going on inside
the chat as I'm talking as other people
are talking about the chat it's
incredible it's incredible how many of
you show up every single day and engage
with this show so it makes me it makes
me happy it makes me keep going you are
the reason why this microphone stays
powered against
fascism
um let's
see
um the What is the the button for oh
then what is the button for you're
talking about the U the button on the
turkey Paula I the button on the turkey
if it pops apparently this is just rumor
now I don't know we may have to look
this up but
apparently the the button on the turkey
if it pops it's too done it's overdone
you want it not to pop which doesn't
make any sense does it because once it
pops you're like well [__] I can't turn
back time now you would think it would
be to say when it's done but I I I I
heard tail that it's
doesn't do that uh speaking of um the
[__] them fan
and and Thanksgiving here is some
[__] [__] them Thanksgiving for you
guys here it is FM Thanksgiving you see
it there oh that's the mark Wayne's
engine here it is here's more FM
Thanksgiving so this is more [__] them
Thanksgiving from from me and rat to
you yes thank you R and this is more
more of our [__] them Thanksgiving from
us to you so we we appreciate you guys
showing up every single weekday Monday
through Friday here on the Tony Michaels
podcast don't forget as you're out
talking to your relatives to point
out that they should watch this show you
know what I mean you should spread the
word while you're out and about
especially to your manga relatives oh
[__] let's get them in here and really
piss them
off that's what you should do get them
in
here and let's get them pissed
off why why did we keep typing that one
in uh let's
see
let's see what else what other question
does anybody else have any other
questions here oh here here's a good
politics question Yogi says do the
Democrats have a plan to combat
2025 are you saying um do they have a
plan to combat it or or or to expose
it because the plan to combat it is to
win the
election um and we talked about this the
other day with Rachel
bofer and Rachel knows that it's a huge
threat and mighty librarian over at the
library of democracy is g to be doing a
video series
on uh project 20225 and already has a
video out rat did you watch that video
that Mighty librarian did yeah it was a
great video wasn't it it was ftic it was
a it's a video on the Heritage
Foundation really exposing the Heritage
Foundation and their Roots the fascist
roots that they have um so go check that
out at library democracy just go to
Theon michaels.com pan on down to the
library democracy on the watch and
listen Tab and you'll see Library
democracy
there she did a great video on that and
it's a start to a series so we're going
to do a lot of content um
rebutting project 2025 here on the show
but I I want to reassure you because
there is going to come a point where
Republicans are going to lean into
project 2025 like they're going to be
all excited like yeah this is our game
plan we we're going we're going we're
going to really do this project 2025 and
I think a lot of people are doubting me
on that at this point but they're
definitely going to lean into this and
the reason why is because the reason why
in 2022 that there wasn't a red wave
they leaned into shutting down the
government do you remember that 2022
they were like we're going to shut down
the government that's the first thing
we're going to do [__] the government
and people are like what we're electing
you to the government why would why
would we elect you to shut it down what
the [__] are you talking about and they
did not they did not have a blue or red
wave it was more like a a pink
Shir then a red
wave let's see uh ba here says Tony do
you think some states will declare the
the legislature hands the right to
select the president instead of the
popular vote I mean each state does have
a little different way that they select
electors I think that's what you're
asking is um whether they'll select
electors or not I know a lot of people
are are are scared of
this I know I get it because of some of
the [__] that happened in
2020 and I understand that that
Republicans are going to do everything
they can do to
cheat right um
but it
really we have we have to keep calm
about this but we have to do the work
also and even in 2020 when he really
wanted them to steal it right when no
one was really paying attention that
they were stealing it because that's
really kind of
the the quiet part out loud here is that
you remember Ducey the governor at the
time in Arizona when he was signing to
certify the electors of Arizona after
Arizona
reluctantly even after the whole Rusty
Bowers thing and they were trying to get
the the the the state reps to overturn
the results and give Trump the electors
and the fake elector scheme even Ducey
got a call from Donald Trump while he
was signing the certification for those
electors and ignored his phone
call
folks we we didn't know some of that
stuff was happening and those folks who
were working to try to overturn our
election knew that we didn't know some
of that stuff is happening we are going
to have our eyes on the ball now and
they know we're going to be
watching so I wouldn't get too excited
about that kind of stuff just like I
wouldn't get excited about the 14th
Amendment [__] that people keep talking
about that stuff is all [__]
distraction I don't even know why
[__] people are even considering that
as a [__] option what a stupid
[__] idea in the first
place that's the only reason why I
attacked Glenn too and he had some
[__] video that he put out on Twitter
today talking about it again he can't
stop [__] talking about it that's why
I knock him on it it's the dumbest [__]
ever judges are deciding against his
stupid [__] wants he wants this to
happen it doesn't mean it it's going to
happen you can want in one hand and [__]
in the other and see which one fills up
first my dad used to tell me that you
can want in one hand and [__] in the
other and see which one fills up first
just because you want Trump to be 14th
does not mean he's going to and to sit
and talk about something that you want
that isn't going to happen is a waste of
[__]
time it's much more important to talk
about [__] that we can do like engage in
our
democracy register voters get turnout
get people [__] strategically
outraged about certain things so that
they'll make sure that their vote counts
and that they do the battle at The
Ballot
Box not inside some stupid [__] Echo
chamber on a YouTube channel that that
where Justice matters well Glenn if
Justice matters then accept the [__]
decision that was made by the
judge that's all I'm saying because
that's what he said in his video today
is that he's not willing to accept the
decision that was made by the judge well
that just isn't Justice is it it's
[__] dumb so I wouldn't get too hung
up on exactly the electors yet right
don't go don't get too hung up on that
yet um and and how our democracy can be
stolen there so uh let's
see uh oh oh here here Gracie says and
and it's I welcome desent I welcome
desent to the show I don't block people
just because they disagree with me I
don't block people because they say mean
things to me I don't give a [__] really
you're it's your choice to to [__]
like me or dislike me it's your choice
to come here and tell me I'm wrong or
prove to me that I'm wrong that that
that that's up to you I'm not gonna
block you or try to keep you out now my
moderators do their job very well so you
know don't don't [__] around or
you but we are not here to silence
descent um because Gracie says really
talk to Michael Cohen about Rush the
prosecution and get back to me Michael
Cohen didn't rush the
prosecution I I want to give you I want
to give you Insight on that Michael
Cohen wasn't rushed to prosecution he
was prosecuted for a crime that he
committed I I and I and I understand and
I understand that that that that Michael
had individual one on his indictment and
that was Trump and that Trump didn't pay
that
price like Michael Cohen did but I mean
we're in a situation now where Michael
Cohen's testifying in a Civil Trial
where Donald Trump's going to lose his
entire [__] business so I
mean you know tit fortat maybe I don't
know and it's only because Michael Cohen
because he was his Donald Trump's
personal attorney helping him commit
these
crimes at that time that he knows this
evidence and he knows how Donald Trump
was committing this crime
so I I I I've talked to Michael I've
interviewed Michael I've had Michael on
my show I had Michael on the select
hearings I've talked to Michael
personally and I gotta tell you that I
don't know that Michael has ever said
that he denied that he committed
crimes he pled guilty to them in a
federal court and he did his prison time
for those crimes but to act like Michael
Cohen is somehow innocent or something
like that or that he was persecuted I
mean he definitely he definitely wasn't
treated as Fair as Donald Trump was on
those indictments individual one but I
mean am I supposed to feel sorry for d
for Michael Cohen paying the price for
the crimes that he commended I I mean I
don't know what you're saying
exactly
okay Mt Max says we are awesome aren't
we you are you guys are pretty [__]
awesome there is no lie there even the
ones that like to come and descent you
guys are pretty [__] awesome
too I welcome descent I think descent is
good I think that's what drives
democracy I really do when we descent
against each other when we have
conflicting ideas and we have to
compromise and we have to talk to each
other we have to actually figure out a
way for us to coexist inside a space
where we don't always agree just like
this show just like this chat or the one
on Facebook that I'm banned
from or on Twitch someone yesterday on
Twitch was saying sometimes Tony's a
dumbass I didn't get a chance to pull it
up I wish I would
have but I did see you out there calling
me a dumbass I I'm fine with that I'm
probably am a dumbass
sometimes I don't
know people probably think I am but it
happens that way sometimes it happens uh
let's see uh Catherine says Tony karaoke
this week no there's no karaoke this
week because it's Thanksgiving but I
will tell you we're gonna have Christmas
karaoke here on December 17th that's
right Sunday December 17th we're going
to do Christmas
karaoke so I'll be singing we'll have
guests sing maybe I can get uh Dr r
bofer she act like she was interested in
singing karaoke didn't she she really
said rat am I yeah I know she was really
interested in singing I almost think I
should invite her to the Christmas
karaoke what do you
think yeah I think that's a good idea
maybe I'll maybe I'll shoot her a text
and see if she wants to come um sing
some Christmas karaoke but no there's no
karaoke tonight we're GNA hang out with
some friends and uh have a drinks
giving but what else do we have any
other questions that we have in the chat
here you guys are going uh Bonkers with
the chat
here Gabe Sanchez I think is gonna join
us here soon and we're GNA talk about
his show he has a show right after this
one it's called what was that live with
the guy with the last name
SES oh let's see here's another
one uh Donald Allen says isn't AG
Garland in a federal Society yeah he is
he is I I don't know if that means what
you think it means if that means that
he's bad or that he's trying to protect
Trump um but if that's if that's the
case then why would Trump be indicted
why would Trump be attacking the
Department of Justice which the AG is in
charge
of so the fact that he's part of the
federal Society doesn't really
mean that it's that he's for Trump and I
don't know I I I think that's what
you're trying to say maybe I'm not
sure uh let's see what else do we have
here any other
[Music]
questions uh Tony your opinion what
ballot initiatives should the Democratic
party put on the ballots in the swing
states in the 2024 election what do you
mean like recreational marijuana are you
talking about like ways to to to uh
Stoke
turnout that's done a lot where they'll
put like referendums on
ballots um to to make sure that people
who want to vote for those things come
out and vote but if you remember in 2020
we we during the pandemic it was one of
the highest turnouts there was and I
don't think that 81 million people voted
for
Biden
um because a lot of those 81 million
people got their ass out there and went
and voted against Trump really does
so oh let's
see Glenn um Augustus says Glenn doesn't
think we sh we should be able to put
Bankers in
jail I'm not sure are you talking about
Glenn number two or Glenn number one or
Glenn number
three people hate when I attack
him they [__] hate it when I attack
Glenn I'm not really attacking him that
much I'm just I'm just telling you that
his opinion sucks what do you want do
you want me to lie to you and someone
somebody the the other day is like
Tony people are not gonna want to watch
you if you keep talking about Glenn and
I'm like you're still here host audience
while repeating
yeah that was the other
[Music]
one they say I repeat myself a lot oh
well what are you gonna do I know
another guy who repeats himself a lot
maybe not as much as me but you know
I've got a car
so I don't know what that has to do wow
oh how's it how's it going Gabe Sanchez
how's it it's going it's going do you
got do you got uh do you got ride yet no
I got to go back uh go back to the the
car rental the rental place oh my God
yeah because yesterday didn't have it or
the other day didn't have it so I was
like all right fine so what what what
car are you looking for at the rental
place is it a compact is it a full size
just a simple sedan God damn I just need
something to get me from point A to
point right that's what I so so are you
gonna need this car for Thanksgiving
holiday yeah I might need it and
depending on whatever the outcome is of
this because I was like okay
well best case scenario my car come they
find my car right best case scenario
they find my car it has some damage to
it and they they're able to repair it
worst case scenario is uh they don't
find my car and then I have to go
through the whole process of getting a
new car right uh I do not anticipate
myself having a
car like either prepare or like repaired
and ready or a new replacement card by
the time Christmas comes around you know
I totally I totally did not realize I
like last week I was like oh this is
only gonna last a few days here we are
next the week after and I'm still able
to goof on you about not having a car
it's ridiculous it's ridiculous it is in
it is insane so uh yeah for anyone
wondering uh my car was stolen I called
yesterday to uh get an update and the
police were like yeah still stolen so
there's that man did they really say
that still stolen yeah I called we just
checked the paperwork and um look I I
called I called the police station and I
talked to the detective who's you know
who's G who's I've been talking to and
what's his first name I don't want to I
don't want to doct him but what I don't
know he just gave me his last name
detective blank that's his name is
detective blank no no
why I'm just I'm just trying I just
trying to get a sense of this character
that we're trying to I have no idea
don't know what his first name is I only
know his last name he's a detective he
works in the the car
um the car theft impound whatever oh so
this is his his job is to track down
stolen cars yeah he's just not very good
at his job well you also have to
understand that like this car is in a
sea of millions of other
cars right in various different areas
could be in LA county or others but they
have no idea the only way and I and I
asked them I was like how do you guys
know to look out for my car because
obviously like my license plate or
whatever he's like well unless it's
abandoned or there was an accident like
we're not going to know to look out for
it so unless someone calls it in we
won't know where it is so I was like oh
[__] all right so then so then I
said um I was like all right well do you
have any idea on what's going on he's
like I don't know there could be variety
of things they could it could be these
kids someone else could have stolen it
uh these kids could have replaced the
plates with different ones so we now
know we can't identify your car by just
like a glance of the license
plate it's a [__] [__] show man so um
there is some breaking news but Eve says
here she she drive you around huh I oh
yeah e says La you live in right yeah I
mean if you're like going to give free
rides gab s is like yeah really cool we
got to go like 45 minutes for
Thanksgiving so I'm cool with that I
mean yeah well it's not only me it's me
my two dogs and my partner which by the
way that reminds me okay zephy in the
[__] Discord was like gab says
partner that makes me think something
else is going on I don't know what you
think would be going on what do you what
does that mean zy what does it mean yeah
what does that mean dog do I have no
idea I say that just out
of who she is there you go you know who
it is now oh oh so he was saying he was
saying he was saying you know like I
have no idea I I don't know either I
don't know I have no idea I was confused
I was like what is he what is he
alluding to I'm very confused right now
you know we we had like a and cause skip
on Discord he'll game every every couple
weeks he'll game while I talk yeah play
like U the [__] it called red Red Dead
2 or something Red Dead Redemption 2
yeah yeah that yeah so so so he'll G
he'll be playing that game while I'm
talking [__] and zephy under another
name came in twitch right and then I was
really giving him [__] hell and he's
like oh this is zephy I'm like yeah I
know I don't give a
[__] um a lot of people are saying in
the in the in the chat that Ze likes to
[__] around well zy you [__] around with
Gabe Sanchez and you might just you
might just find out I mean he's willing
to commit insurance fraud with George
Santos on his stolen car
so maybe zephy stole yeah maybe zephy
stole my car he that could be maybe that
was just like a prank gone wrong and I
he's like oh [__] I didn't think he was
gonna talk about it online tell the
world about how his car got St oh my God
oh my God maybe that's what
happened I have some breaking news and
doesn't it's not good news um it looks
like rainbow bridge between US and
Canada is closed following an
explosion um looks like and I'm not
really sure but this just happened uh
not too long ago but looks like um the
rainbow bridge between US and Canada
closed following explosion an incident
involved the vehicle Crossing into the
US from Canada oh my God now all
Thanksgiving we're going to hear about
oh build a wall Bild wall canidon
canidon
Canadians so what happens what happens
when they just
uh oh wow I'm watching the Discord right
now zephy loves that photo of me he
really
does I just
came there you go I'm gonna come I'm GNA
come don't come on a more serious note
here's the statement from
Governor hokel I I've have just been
briefed on the situation that occurred
at the Rainbow Bridge in Buffalo at my
direction the New York State Police is
active working with the FBI joint
terrorism task task force now just
because the terrorism task force on this
doesn't necessarily mean that it is
Terrorism it just means if I had to
guess yeah if it was
terrorism it's probably some right-wing
extremist well I mean isn't that how we
have to is that where we go first I just
don't I just well I don't know I
leftists have been a little wonky these
days so who knows but uh I will say that
I'm going to safely assume that if it if
it is domestic terrorists right it's or
it was domestic terrorism it's
probably if I had to assume right-wing
extremists and Governor hokel goes on to
say I am traveling to Buffalo to meet
with law enforcement and emergency
responders and will update New Yorkers
uh when more information becomes
available so the the bridge between US
and Canada there in Buffalo New York the
Rainbow Bridge um
now it makes me even think more that
it's a right winger because they're like
Rainbow Bridge must be one of them gay
Bridges or some [__] like that you know
even though people say oh my pet soand
so crossed over the Rainbow Bridge it's
crazy or or you you drive on the Rainbow
Bridge when you're playing [__] Mario
Kart it's true it's all gay it's all
it's all Li turds it's all
woke what did you use speaking of woke
now I I kind of covered this in the
front of the show but did you see that
Jason chaitz likes woke turkey look at
this man here's the
thingy so I I covered this turkey thing
live yesterday yeah and I was like here
follow along and I went through and I
was like look I looked up I know where
he lives in Utah in the Alpine Highland
par Highland area and we went through
and I was like most likely he bought it
from Meyers and in my tweet I said
there's three places that are nearby
Myers Macy's and Walmart he wouldn't go
to the other two because they're like no
por the POR shop there yeah yeah he's
Gotta Go Gotta Go to the bougie ass spot
so I go okay fine so before the show
yesterday I called up Myers because they
don't have their stuff online and I said
hey is this like the high-end specialty
meet spot is like this is like the most
expensive one that one would go to in
the area and he's like yeah and I go
great okay how much is it per pound and
he's like oh it's 4.99 per pound and I
go got it and then just to get an idea I
was like all right so nearly five bucks
let's say a 20 pound bird he goes that's
a big bird you got a big you got a big
group trying to feed and I was like I'm
just trying to get an idea you know I
was like making a turkey for the first
time kind of thing you know just talking
to him I don't know [__] about turkey he
was like if you want a 20 pound I mean
like we sell up to 30 pound Birds over
here which are big because if you want a
20 pound Bird that's probably going to
get you like in the 17 18 person party
range because you typically feed a pound
to a pound and a half per
person and he's like so if you got a big
party yeah definitely recommend that uh
and I was like okay great thanks you
know thanks for the help and so I went
on the show and I was like look I
guarantee that he bought it from Myers I
guarantee he bought it from the bgie ass
place and then he tweeted and it was
like oh here's the photo and I was like
you [__] idiot you just [__]
revealed it yourself when you go on and
you complain about this stuff about a
$90 bird even though you paid another he
Li yeah he paid he could have totally
been like Joe Biden totally made me pay
$115
and it's not just that it was a
22.85% per
pound it's crazy Ric it's crazy and the
thing is when you have a when you have a
family you're like oh most most times
you're like a 10 12 pounds that's it
that's all I need for my like four
person family or
whatever and he's obviously going so
again I don't know is he
Mormon I don't know I have no idea I'm
just wondering like maybe that's why he
is he from Colorado or Utah He's from
Utah I thought he's from Colorado no man
he's in Utah so that's what I'm asking
is he Mormon does he have a big family
you know like color Utah what do you
want wives thing I don't know what do
you want from me what do you want from
me he is from Utah isn't he yeah I
saying I know where he's from he lives
in Alpine Utah that's why I had to look
it up and be like how many grocery
stores are in the Alpine area well F
dude I did the fact checking
man I just I just went on the show
yesterday and disparaged him and lied
about it I didn't give a [__] I said
people yep people saying he's Mormon so
maybe maybe does he have like many wives
or something I
well I I said that he bought it from
Whole Kelly
bronze never even heard of Kelly Bron
yeah neither at I you know what I did
you know how I did my research I went
online like I want to know the most
expensive turkey you can buy in the
United States and this is the most
United States nine pounds is [__]
$133 I hope it's like a turducken or
something no no this is just a [__]
turkey man apparently they give hand
jobs to it they give massages to it I
don't know I
don't uh oh oh Hey listen up we got some
breaking news we got some breaking news
here hang on let me let me flip it over
here everyone needs to thank Mike
Johnson for releasing January 6 tapes
apparently arrest warrant has been
issued for another MAA terrorist um who
the who has now been found based on the
tapes that Mike Johnson has released
yeah so here's the arrest one see what
they didn't this is the problem and I
want people to understand this this is
the problem that Margy Taylor green ran
into originally she this is uh last year
I think it was she was like release the
January 6 tapes release the footage and
there's a couple counts on a couple
counts online the uh the like um uh
domestic Terror like home domestic
terrorists or whatever it is and the
other one that's like the seditionist
hunters or whatever
which go through and analyze the actual
footage and photos from that day and
then find those people online and then
then notify the authorities to say hey
we found the
person so they said oh that's great yes
release all the footage give us the
footage we want it all because we don't
have it we've only seen what's been
available online from self-reported
stuff but also from January 6 committee
so please give us all this stuff and
then margar Taylor green quickly back
stepped it was like oh well look they're
going to come at they're they're calling
me a domestic terrorist they're going to
come after me and it's like look unless
you have something to hide there should
be no reason that you would want to hide
this these tapes that you've been Mo
bitching and moaning about for the past
x amount of months so when I see margar
Taylor green tweet out and then again
backpedal on the whole oh look it's an
FBI agent we knew there were feds
undercover it turns out it was just a
vape then you've got Mike Johnson being
like yep we released the tapes which
also are censored in some
ways and then you've got people being
like awesome we have the tapes now we've
identified new people that we were not
aware of
so another
[__] rake step face plant egg all
over this is what I thought as soon as
that happened I'm like well a it's going
to get more people arrested B it's only
going to prove that those people
arrested are manga supporters not
[__] FBI agents that are dressed as
manga supporters and
see good [__] them let them let them
[__] release as many tapes as they
want right you got to comply right these
are the people who want Justice to be
served and
delivered so they shouldn't be upset
about this they should not be mad at the
fact that once again much like Jason
shavitz much like Mark Wayne
Mullen they created their own problem no
one forced them to do these things no
one forced them to go to the capital no
one forced them to buy that $115 turkey
no one forced them to buy
that what is it like
$80,000 F250 diesel truck nobody forced
these people to do anything wait wait I
have news on that too here's some news
um let's let's listen to how gas prices
are much more expensive now due to Biden
let's listen good news for consumers
though with a gallon of gas now at the
lowest Thanksgiving price since
2020 G whoops I thought I thought it
thanks thanks Brandon remember that
series they used to do no this really is
I've got a I'm working on I'm trying to
get this EP what was that episode out
before tomorrow which is
basically calling out these two but
other Republicans as well but the idea
that actually the econom is working
biomics works you can think you can
Biden for the reduction in inflation but
the other part that I find hilarious is
Mark Wayne Mullen being like oh man I
paid 468 then he gets F checked got a
community notes on it that was like I we
don't know where you bought this gas but
based on our data collection of Oklahoma
you paid some outlier amount the real
amount is like $320 or something like
that he he must have went to the to the
fancy gas station like Jason Chait went
to the fancy store you pump it's where
you pump the gas and they pumped the the
turkey as well right that's probably
what it is that's speaking of turkey in
the January 6 here's margorie Taylor
green on uh I'm triggered with Donald
Trump J I was also scared because no one
could tell me that those were Trump
supporters I fully believe that they
were antifa BLM Riders the same ones
that we saw cause over two billion
dollars in damage in in American cities
across the country the previous year and
um I was actually scared and luckily
there was another member of Congress I'm
not going to name him right now let
people read it in the book that that
helped me a lot and I'm also very
thankful he was armed that day because I
really believe in good guys with
guns oh my god oh man her her incessant
belief that it was antifa
BLM and the fact that she goes and they
cause they love that narrative they
caused $2 billion doll in damage
ignoring the fact that the bugalo boys
and other white supremacists started
Fires at the Minneapolis Police Station
at the Auto Zone and various other
places where they're like it was all
these leftist antifa BLM
people except the fact that the people
who were caught for committing these
crimes were not part of BLM they were
not part of
antifa which again you would think that
they would support antifa if they say
that other people are Fascist and
they're anti-fascist but now they're
really anti-
anti-fascist oh my God I'm going to go
into this magga Ben guy today I I want
to show you this one before you go on
your show because your show's about to
start but I want I want to give people a
sense of when you see BLM like is this
BLM in the room with us now watch this
game just landed in Phoenix and not
surprise surprise flights all over the
country New York Chicago DC and the
biggest one North Carolina lots of
Africans heading to North Carolina
Africans just came across the border
Africans to your community Charlotte
they're going everywhere guys wait going
everywhere do they let black people do
they let black people travel in this
country gab Sanchez for crying out loud
hold on hold on before I go I just gotta
ask the question is there like a holiday
right soon maybe I is there a reason why
people might be traveling could be maybe
May crazy maybe the cost of Airline
transportation is lower so more people
are willing to travel more during the
holidays oh and God forbid we have
people from other countries who live
here or are visiting but hey Maga Ben
over here who by the way there's a
thread that was started in my uh in a
tweet that I made and people are
bringing up a whole bunch of [__] that I
wasn't aware of and I was like oh I
might have to do a little what was that
on you but I'll cover them on the show
and and cover those comments well go
over to your show get the hell over
there Happy Thanksgiving my friend go do
what was that line get the H over there
the H over there all right everybody
thank you for tuning in don't stick
around if you're on YouTube and twitch
which I'm not on Facebook right now so I
wish I could say that but I'm
not if you're on YouTube if you're on
Twitch stick around gab Sanchez what was
that live right after this don't forget
to go use the promo code turkey 12
that's turkey2 turkey1
12 just go to the Tony michaels.com pan
on down grab your tattoo collection
merch or your even my cat hates Ted Cruz
or even my dog hates Ted Cruz merch all
the merch store you get 12% off when you
use the promo Co code turkey 12 that's
turkey1 12 turkey2 go to the Tony
michaels.com Happy Thanksgiving stick
around Gabe Sanchez is what was that
live is up next on Twitch and YouTube
have a great weekend have a safe holiday
we'll see you you back next Monday same
time same place Surfs Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebor H ass
speaking